apple products are notorious for being
insanely expensive after mastering the
art of conspicuous consumption the tech
company seems to be hell bent on pushing
its customers pricing boundaries i mean
this is a trillion dollar company whose
market cap is even higher than the gdp
of switzerland so why are apple's
products more expensive than its
competitors is it simply because of
loyal customers who just pay to have
their favorite brands logo on each of
apple's luxury products what exactly is
it about apple that makes people go
insane every time the company releases a
new product with essentially the same
old specs do you think the hype is even
worth the price hikes does apple like to
put an unfair price on loyalty curious
about all that well keep watching to
learn more about why apple's products
are getting so expensive
1. apple tax to become the proud owner
of an iphone ipad or macbook you have to
pay a little something called an apple
tax this substantial tax is the price
for top notch premium products an apple
ecosystem exact insanely large amounts
of money because hey paying more is
basically a norm for their devoted
customers sometimes these prices are
mildly off-putting but recently apple
has gone way overboard with the most
bizarre price hikes imaginable this
premium cost is infamously known as the
apple tax which can be traced back to
2001 when the original ipad came out
with a price tag of 399 dollars and was
inflated to 579 dollars so how exactly
does apple make its users cough up this
hefty tax well consider this situation
apple sells its 256 gigabyte mac for 1
on the other hand a windows laptop with
arguably better specs will have the same
price tag so the price is the same but
quality not so much let's take another
example of apple tax although apple has
boasted about certain updates to the mac
mini macbook air ipad pro and apple
pencil each one comes with a huge price
hike they have even raised prices of mac
accessories based on the new space gray
color here are some basic examples of
mac prices blowing through the roof mac
mini the mac mini was priced at 499
dollars at entry level but since then it
comes at 799 dollars and it doesn't even
include a keyboard mouse or display
mac pro apple also revealed their five
thousand dollar mac pro display
accompanied by a thousand dollar monitor
stand one thousand dollars for a stand
you heard that correctly
[Music]
macbook air and while we're on the topic
of apple selling overpriced macbooks
let's not forget about the macbook air
which debuted at 1
899. with merely 64 gigabyte storage
another example was in 2015 when it
debuted the 10 000
gold apple watch which had roughly 300
worth of gold in weight all apple had to
do was slap on the logo to attract
buyers and there you have it its most
groundbreaking feature is that it allows
you to communicate with unrivaled
accuracy that you have ten thousand
dollars
however this isn't even the most
troubling side of the apple tax the
thing is apple isn't even sparing
entry-level items before selling them
off with a huge price tag that is sure
to blow your minds take this one now the
base model apple watch experienced a
considerable price hike from 329 dollars
to 399 dollars the most stunning apple
tax was on ipad pro which experienced a
price hike by going from 649 dollars to
799 dollars you heard that right folks
and that doesn't even take into account
the extra 50 bucks you have to pay for
greater capacity all in all this brings
us to a staggering price tag of
for a maximum capacity 12.9 inch
cellular ipad pro model but hey did you
think that apple stops pushing the price
boundaries of its customers even after
some backlash of course not while we're
on the topic of apple tax we should talk
about the way apple handles storage
because anyone who wishes to buy apple
products should take a crash course on
apple storage 101 to brace themselves
for some financial shocks it's
essentially pretty simple if you wish to
upgrade your storage pay up the bigger
the storage space available the more
expensive the gadget will be eventually
the prices get higher and higher until
they reach the extreme level for apple
computers so it goes without saying that
going overboard is the modus operandi
for apple another form of the apple tax
is observed in apple's accessories like
the premium keyboards that are sold for
129 dollars and the premium mouse for 79
even the cables are insanely expensive
so that's the first main reason why
apple products are getting expensive
because of the ever climbing apple tax
two rising prices of chips the second
reason why apple's products are getting
so expensive is due to the rising price
of semiconductors the global shortage of
supplies like chips and conductors has
raised the manufacturing fees imposed by
the world's largest chip maker companies
so we can safely state that perhaps
apple shouldn't be blamed entirely for
its ridiculously overpriced items for
example the chipmaker qualcomm is
expected to charge higher prices for
supplying crucial parts to apple for its
iphone 13 and unfortunately the users
will have to face the brunt of these
soaring prices when apple will create
even more costly gadgets apple will be
forced to release high-end products to
compensate for the cost consequences and
users will have to cough up even more
money
3. software ok so let's face it apple is
singularly unique for developing its ios
versions from scratch every time an
apple product gets an upgrade or update
it's all thanks to apple as there is no
other third-party software involved this
sets apple apart from android and
windows now the thing is you don't see
that with android phones and windows
devices because both of them receive a
ready-made operating system from google
and of course the software from google
and microsoft is relatively free of bugs
and is pre-tested too on the other hand
apple designs and tests its software for
itself considering that they have to pay
for all the research and development
themselves unlike say android that racks
up quite a lot of expenditures in fact
apple had to pay a whopping 18.75
billion dollars in 2020 for research and
development so it's evident that
consumers have to pay for that out of
their own pockets too since apple
charges them for directly managing ios
software let's move on to the fourth
reason for soaring apple price tags
4. psychological if you have a friend
who owns like a gazillion apple products
you must be familiar with that intense
feeling of envy and wistfulness and who
wouldn't feel that way let's be honest
here or maybe you're someone who buys
iphones and macbook pros simply for show
it just makes you feel very oh so
premium and special well that's exactly
the sort of emotions apple wants to
incite from everyone who looks up at the
blazing billboards it's all a
psychological game where either you
spend loads of money on apple products
for personal gratification or you feel
envious enough to scrounge up enough
money to buy the iphone and boy does
apple capitalize on that whenever the
tech giant announces a new apple product
when not even a year has gone by for the
existing model you'll find people simply
starving for the new item and boom a
wild buzz is created that apple
intensifies by using age-old formulas
like pre-ordering and there you have it
folks apple has become a venus fly trap
for users seeking psychological
satisfaction in that iconic logo that
should explain why apple products keep
getting more and more expensive however
that's not all as you will see next
5. slowdown of sales last but not least
the reason apple's products are becoming
so costly is because of the sales
slowdowns now apple has been facing a
serious downtrend because hey that one
thousand dollar price tag sure doesn't
look very nice anymore anyway some
products have reached maximum market
saturation as there isn't any market
left to take over or expand into for
example the sales of gadgets like the
iphone mac and ipad have seen a steady
downturn since 2015. anyone with a
smidgen of marketplace sense can figure
out how terribly detrimental that is for
apple what if the potential investors
and analysts took a look at their
revenues and went nope not good enough
so if you're apple what do you do voila
you raise the prices of all your
existing gadgets to compensate for a
decline in sales and the cherry on top
the flourishing revenues will show the
competitors and investors that business
is simply booming simple as that so
basically apple is overcharging
customers to bring in so much revenue
that it will cover up for the sales
slowdown with that we are done with
today's video thank you for watching see
you next time peace out